olá pessoal aqui quem fala é o da área
que sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo e o estrago de jequié esta é
aquela em troca comecem todos os meus
vídeos desde há três anos atrás diz lado
começo muito longe lá para trás
meu e hoje somos um faq milhão de
inscritos
no meu 1 milhão é muita gente é muita
gente
são seis da manhã agora eu vim aqui pro
estúdio esta hora porque eu sentia que
era meu esta hora que tem que ser ouvido
porque estava sentindo mesmo eu preciso
falar agora toledo estou mais calmo meu
quando em 1999 ontem que passar por um
milhão
meu bater aquela emoção forte pra
solano se choraram na hora de
saltar e vá rua tudo no mexe a eu não
consegui fazer este logo na hora meu é
muita emoção e eu só em fazer um vídeo
chorarem e não consegui falar nada de
jeito mas é isso foi um dia calmo me
olha já para o canal evangélico 1 milhão
eu esteja ligado a qualquer candidato
conseguisse step ao detran piauí não há
nada que tira agora esse milhão milton
ivan vai foi isso eu fui isso só a sério
muito obrigado a todos vocês
ontem quando chegou a um milhão eu vim
aqui por twitter muita gente terá os
problemas muitos de vocês foi dizem
coisas meu incríveis eu percebi que um
botão tinha lances que vejam só
bárbara lopes um botão de selantes logo
na hora tipo em que estava e para
atingir 1 milhão né quando no mercosul é
uma coisa que fazia o papel de selmes
brutal meu lindo lindo meu você enviar
uma coisa espetacular fone clubes do
instagram a partilharem tudo meu fãs no
twitter foi mil fãs no facebook eu muita
coisa muito tempo fiquei superfeliz
sério outros de outubro faremos para
banho e também meu eo mais incrível da
estrutura quando você atingir esta marca
tipo é tão bom ver as pessoas que têm
por que vocês gostam de povos isolados
que pagarem este foi mesmo tempo é ó são
mesmo ou só pegar um pouquinho
era tudo vai ficar muito obrigado por
vocês maturarem até aqui somos agora 1
milhão
meu e eu confesso que na altura em que o
conselho o canal que pensava o é ok eu
comecei agora o canal tem tipo 20 mil
inscritos 30 mil eo pincel ok 100 mil é
aquela meta fácil é que elas metem que
se postar vídeos com rua tirado de seu
evoluir e seu tipo sentir essa ideia
essa missão eu vou conseguir chegar aos
100 mil
mas quando diziam a imaginá lá quanto cá
já um milhão eu pensava sempre um milhão
era aquela meta inalcançável tipo eu
achava mesmo que eu não conseguia estava
fora da minha porque dá um tempo chegar
a 1 milhão mesmo e aí que eu pensava
mesmo que não conseguia ficar 1 milhão e
eu agora vou eu sou idiota edson fachin
idiota claro que se eu trabalhar pra
tudo que eu tenho que achar que
deve que faça fluir meu eu buscar é todo
lado tal como vocês que puniu da
pescaria tudo igual só vai só faixa só
faz como vai ficar isso vai acontecer
notas frias notas e não sei eu não mas
eu tive quando disseram que eu poderia
chegar a 1 milhão que eu não acreditava
mesmo eu achava mesmo que não era
possível e hoje é que estou graças a
você e todas as pessoas que têm apoiado
muito para vencer amanhã ao anti por ter
chegado a 1 milhão é o meu brown também
chegou meu nós começar juntos lá lá
muito atrás
estamos agora a gente a 1 milhão tipo
chegou a 1 milhão e dos despojos ganha 1
milhão
meu brutal mesmo protal para mais para
baixo também houve ninguém escapa agora
sim um script e meu cérebro tem sido uma
companhia brutal tipologia da makita os
vídeos também meu é um grande amigo
muito fish e merece pra mil por
bairros mesmo por aí mas também o caso
está quase a chegar aos quatro milhões
caso é bombar caso é bom para escalar os
quatro milhões muito rápido
meu está tudo acontecendo ao mesmo tempo
está a ser uma onda desse tipo de
felicidade de concretização brutal mesmo
eu curto pra e quando atingir
estas metas de vir também os meus amigos
que estão à minha volta a atingir meu é
brutal tempo total gasto juntos nisto é
um lindo e vocês fazem parte disso
também tipo você já que torna isso
possível os fãs fã-clubes do instagram
o facebook o tubo eu topo já entrevistou
foi remover água para lá na ob a sério
eu não sei que ele sente que é muita
coisa é meu é um milhão de inscritos
eu não sou eu nem sei por que fazer isso
e eu pensava que estava calma com a
imagem ou não tocar ainda estou feliz
pra intuindo do aqui pé mas bom
só ó
muito obrigada vez nos jogos desse tipo
obrigado jogos disso não ainda não estou
obrigado obrigado a outra vez
obrigado também a catarina a minha
namorada e trip ou para lutar todos os
dias comigo a aturar me por fazer tão
feliz como faz sem ela o tipo não era
feliz pra fazer isto e sem ela não tinha
aquela policial que porque é aquela sair
argumental sabem sabe quando você estica
o acórdão é sentirem-se inferiores de
toda a gente sabe quando você tira um
acórdão com um tipo c sem vontade de
fazer nada sabem quando você seja o
órgão em seguros pra sabe quando
você se parece com um desabafa a vossa
volta e depois tenham aquela pessoa que
o brilho semfaz que pune mexer outra vez
em essen e sentirem fortes ou perde essa
pessoa é katrina é minha namorada por
isso eu amava muito e obrigado por fazer
de mim
brincar e não chorar né
muito obrigado também aos pais a
catarina que sem as pessoas fantásticas
que são que nunca conheci da série eu
nunca conheci uma família tão brutal
quanto de katrina ser os pais dela irmã
dela sobre os segmentos inclusive os
pais da cantora nina ajudaram a
construir o estúdio já condenaram o
espaço eu sei que fizeram aqui obra
portanto eu sei eu não era nada o
carnaval é portanto muito obrigado a
vocês mesmo e visto que eu vou ficar com
catarina para sempre e vou ter tempo
para absorver compensar por isso que é
só uma questão de tempo né pai ou não
não sei obrigado a todos e meu obrigado
obrigado a todos
já não só um milhão aparece limpa um
funk em mirassol willian união
eu não sei se vocês se percebiam lista e
eu não sei se algum vídeo meus colegas
de escola no drama lá eu acho que só
lembram se daquela altura em que eu
tinha tipo 200 mil inscritos foi àquela
altura em que estava na casa da minha
mãe e eu construir aquela menina em casa
gervinho dentro do meu quarto para
isolar o som e tal
nessa altura era pra ter acabado com o
canal era pra que botava um milésimo de
milímetro do pensamento de fechar o
canal que eu ia fechar o canal mesmo se
não fosse aquela tipo aquela ideia de
fazer acabar ali dentro eu ia fechar o
canal porque na altura que por eu quando
fazia vídeo jorrava muito alto já que
estava sem parar marvel muita confusão e
depois poderiam chamar eventualmente a
polícia e tal meu que eu sinto muito
confortável a fazer os meus vídeos e
nessa altura eu estava mesmo a fechar o
canal porque não conseguia estar a fazer
um dos vídeos e não tinha dinheiro pra
fazer isolamento quarto e não tinha
dinheiro e com uma nova casa é de 161
nessa altura de uma aquela ideia tipo a
cair não consigo fazer vídeos o que eu
faço vou parar o canal
sim é isso que eu vou fazer o que tiver
saída eu ia parar o canal méxico
enquanto estava sei lá fazer o que vem o
thriller e bad boy construir uma faca em
casa dentro do meu quarto mas tem uma
coisa boa é low cost e eu fui investigar
foi investigar meu low cost o que é que
eu faço com primeiras comprou comprou
pedra como faz uma parada em cimento que
é que eu faço eu fui investigar
encontrei em caso de jardim numa loja e
foi lá buscar a casa mantém lá a casa
não vamos que busca maneiras fazer
também os vídeos de iniciais netbooks
volte a mostrar isso é que eu acho que
mostrei na altura meu isso não fosse
essa a minha ideia tipo construir logo
aquela cena e eu ia fechar o canal que
essa hora eu não ia ter um milhão que
têm agora à atitude
sei lá que idiota açúcar meu eu ia ser
um idiota e resume concluindo só nunca
nunca na vossa vida e desistam de fazer
aquilo que vocês gostam de fazer
produtos faço lhe já sei lá meu lutem
até a última gota de paciência que você
está indo sei lá meu nome todo o
dinheiro como obstáculo ou falta dela é
não é tão só as duas comissões que vocês
têm a nossa volta como obstáculo
eu não coloquei nada disso enquanto tipo
só vai só vai até a última tipo
esconder-me um soco não tem
a mim não dá quito tem uma parede não dá
pra passar aí vocês farão o meu vai até
a última vai te ir encontrar aparelhos
forem contra ela button cinco vezes nela
e que contou com esta energia eu não saí
mais tempo nunca desistam dos nossos
sonhos porque se eu desistisse naquela
altura eu não ia ter um milhão eu ia ter
um canal com 200 mil inscritos parado
agora e só pessoal que eu ia para fazer
agora eu não saí nem quer pensar nisso
nas fugas wiel pessoal vamos agora para
os 2 milhões
eu quero muito agora fazer mais vídeos
eu sei que por muito pouco o vídeo e
saiu deportivo que dois por semana se
calhar às vezes um por semana
meu mas há muita coisa a combater o que
vou tentar do rio é como explicar
inseguro das coisas que faço tenho medo
que falharam e esse medo de falhar fácil
andar para trás e é aquela insegurança
constante o perfeccionismo mistura meu é
muita coisa acontecer basicamente o meu
psicológico está tudo food mas eu acho
que agora vou conseguir depois de ver
este milhão depois de ver tipo o público
maravilhoso que tem um meu eu não posso
deixar que isso seja um obstáculo ok eu
vou dar ao ouvinte ocres aplicado e em
sol só isso
só está com as folhas folhas eu tô
mal folha se eu tô se eu sei lá meu eu
só vou fazer isso agora só vou fazer que
é novo pra eu vou tentar o tipo por pelo
menos um por dia às vezes conseguir vou
pôr 2000 eu quero muito a avançar com o
canal em grande força e quero que vocês
estejam comigo lá portanto carrega mxn
pessoal aqui das notificações porque o
youtube não ajudou ao meu canal é ter
mais visualizações meu aqui aos veja o
vídeo tem camadas de serena caroto agora
aqui e ver esse vídeo teve bloqueado
três dias treinou três faculdades isto o
youtube pensava que minha também eu era
sangue sangue na casa
ou seja um bote do youtube ou seja com
robô disse ó caixa também mais ainda
portanto vamos bloquear um vídeo três
dias e ninguém vai ver e não vai
conseguir muito usar o vídeo e nada
portanto eu tive com quatro deles tinha
50 mil visualizações que é algo que eu
nunca
tenho sempre muito mais que isso não é
eo youtube é da silveira o pessoal no
youtube ou seja os títulos não é
portanto sol sinimbu está ali só quero
chegar lá e sempre que o para um vídeo
vocês vão ver e vão estar atentos
meu é sério aperta e sininho que agora
agora vai começar meu vai cansar o
upload insano vídeo todo dia dos filhos
por dia se conseguir caso eu falhei
porque alguma urgência meu eu quero
muito muito mesmo focar uma hora só
nisto e dar atenção à minha namorada e
dar atenção à minha família e dar
atenção aos meus amigos que gostam de
mim atenção tudo o que é importante e
pegaram por completo nas coisas do tipo
exteriores e que não fazem falta
ísis folhas o que quer muito e é isso
pessoal muito obrigado a todos vocês a
sério
muito obrigado mesmo eu vou tentar agora
dar o meu máximo o especial vai ser
daqui a uma semana e talvez do mundo tem
que ver até aqui usa em cima da mesa a
dezembro tal desempenho incluindo meu
incluindo de uma famíla blindar que se
chegou lá no estado fala é brutal
bom é isso muito obrigado mesmo preço de
um milhão de inscritos
vocês são um foco ao som do fundo do
coração tipo 6 da manhã eu to party zone
agora vou só para o frango vivo eu vou
dormir que o consumo pra e vou
fazer o que eu mais gosto de fazer que é
acordar foi isso fazer vir frísio para
pessoas felizes e tornar este círculo
vicioso e fui girar no mundo é o que eu
quero muito obrigado a todo o pessoal já
sabe quanto eu posso aqui favorito
fiquem bem até a próxima bola pra
caramba anos embora